the kremlin accuses the u.s of
pressuring other countries to remove
russia from the group of 20 forum of
major economies can washington and its
western allies bar president vladimir
putin from attending the summit this
year in indonesia this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
daddy inabugada the g20 is a major
international platform made up of 19
large economies from the developed and
developing world and the european union
so the bloc's members represent 85
percent of global output 75 of
international trade and two-thirds of
the world's population while economic
and financial policy has dominated
annual summits the agenda was expanded
to include climate change and the
pandemic last year and china says the
g20 is a forum to discuss economic
issues rejecting suggestions russia
could be barred because of its invasion
of ukraine so who controls the g20 and
what lies ahead for the bloc
we'll have our panel in just a moment
but first this report by sarah jarrett
the united states and its western allies
are exploring whether russia can be
barred from the g20 summit in indonesia
later this year
we believe that it cannot be business as
usual for russia in international
institutions and in the international
community russia's ambassador indonesia
says president vladimir putin intends to
travel to bali for the summit
actually it's a
form aimed at
[Music]
improving or
economic
situation and solving economic mostly uh
problems and
of course
expulsion of russia from this kind of
forum will
not help this economic problems to be
resolved the group of 20 was formed in
1999 bringing together the world's
largest industrialized and developing
economies to discuss economic and
financial stability
members from the global south include
argentina and brazil saudi arabia south
africa india and indonesia china has
defended moscow saying the bloc should
be focusing on global economic recovery
from the pandemic
the g20 is the main forum for
international economic cooperation
bringing together the world's major
economies russia is an important member
and no member has the right to expel
another country
australia's prime minister says allowing
vladimir putin to sit with other world
leaders at the summit would be a step
too far
we've been making very clear statements
and representations about our very
strong concerns about the involvement
of russia
in the g20 this year we want the
indonesian g20 to be a great success we
wanted to focus particularly on the
challenges of our region so i think we
need to have people in the room that
aren't invading other countries
the g20 summit was seen as a way for
indonesian president joko widodo to
raise his country's profile on the
international stage and its officials
maintain the block is an economic and
development forum but it now has to
navigate the threat of a western boycott
if president putin decides to attend
the inside story
let's now bring in our guests joining us
from chicago's elizabeth shackleford
she's a senior fellow at the chicago
council on global affairs she's also a
former u.s diplomat from moscow daniel
bochkov he's a fellow at the russian
international affairs council and from
jakarta we have with us thomas suanetto
who's a foreign policy analyst and also
the host of foreign policy talks podcast
he's now involved in business 20
indonesia that's the business engagement
group for the g20 summit welcome to you
all thanks so much for speaking to us on
inside story
daniel bochkov and moscow over to you
first so obviously there's some division
over over whether russia should be
barred from this year's g20 summit to be
held in indonesia how is russia viewing
this
well absolutely right today uh there is
ongoing debate
in the world about whether russia should
really participate in the summit or it's
better to be banned from it and actually
i think that we have so far we have just
only one example of russia being
expelled from very similar kind of uh
organization which
used to be g8 or grade a and actually
it's not really an organization in its
official meaning it's just the gathering
of different countries which share the
same ideas about economy and uh global
governance right and in this case in
this case how is russia viewing it's
possible
borrowing no
yes absolutely impossible and russia
said the same when it was excluded from
g8 in 2014 and it repeats actually the
same narrative currently saying that g20
is not an official organization with
membership status the membership tickets
are not handed over to any country and
so russia cannot be officially banned
from this event and by the way china
yesterday expressed the same opinion
saying that as soon as the g20 summit is
just a kind of forum with countries
which participate on their own wheel
right they cannot be yes they did we'll
talk about china in just a moment but
let me bring in thomas uh noto sonueto
from jakarta so does this put indonesia
in a tough spot because it is the host
of this year's g20 summit as we've been
saying on the one hand it's been very
cautious about how to respond to the
invasion of ukraine on the other hand
this is a very significant event for the
president himself is it not where he
wants to use this opportunity to raise
the country's profile
right um but first of all this is
another unexpected situation right so
indonesia is a president which in many
ways is disrupted division of g20 to
bring transformation and change to the
form
it has known of its uh you know sluggish
response pandemic of its power gap
of its um you know
unactionable outcomes that given by g20
but again this ukraine russia uh crisis
has put indonesia in a very difficult
position the response from the
government is now just plain neutral um
they said that g20 is not a political
form it's an economic development form
and we want to play this
as a consistent position of g20 but of
course we cannot underestimate the
respondent coming from outside from
external parties about russia's presence
it's not only that though is it thomas
because indonesia itself has deep
economic and military ties with russia
so there's a lot at stake for indonesia
itself
that's true but again as a president of
g20 where indonesia should not be acting
as to defend indonesia's foreign policy
itself but also to defend the future of
g20 to bring trust again towards
multilateralism
all right elizabeth uh thanks so much
for your time with us from chicago uh
weigh in on this debate i mean as thomas
was just saying we've not heard from
indonesia's foreign ministry yet on the
decision
that they are going to take do you see
indonesia disinviting russia from this
year's meetings how is this going to
play out
well i do think that indonesia has been
put in a very difficult position because
whether or not they
retain that invitation to russia or
or take it back um this conflict is
going to weigh heavily over the g20 and
pretty much every multilateral um
gathering over that over the coming
weeks and months and you know possibly
getting longer but i think it's very
unfortunate to to try and continue to
maintain that line that somehow economic
issues are not connected to political
issues they certainly are i mean they're
deeply connected and you know we like
the idea and we've kind of uh played
around over the past you know number of
years with this sense of this
multinational
national global environment where you
know we can freely trade but if other
actors aren't playing by the general
rules that allow us to have you know
certainty and predictability and open
trade then you know you simply can't
ignore that and just kind of pretend
like this war isn't happening and this
aggression isn't happening so i think
it's going to be a big decision for
indonesia and then if indonesia decides
to you know maintain that invitation to
us it's going to be the decision by
others whether or not they're going to
try and make a collective action to
prevent that or just decide not to
participate hang on a second so you you
don't agree with those who say look g20
is primarily an economic forum so
you know they question whether it's
appropriate to bring in a political
crisis into this uh framework
it is primarily an economic forum but
you cannot in this interconnected
globalized world separate the two
economics and politics are related and
you know if you have questions about
that just ask china they use their
economic prowess around the world all
the time to achieve political gains just
ask australia or lithuania so i don't
think that it's fair to to pretend like
in some scenarios you can use that
economic weight and others you have to
act as though it's completely separate
from this type of crisis okay got it um
thomas how likely is russia's ejection
given
that there is no clear process for
expelling a country from the group
yes i think the government of indonesia
is now trying to push this rejection
away right and of course uh demand that
the peace negotiation has happened
between ukraine and russia it's still
november i know it's still a couple of
months but we are still very careful as
i mean the government of indonesia i've
seen that the progress and the process
of the
of the peace talk or any ceasefire
agreement between both parties but uh
somehow i agree that uh some
impacts of
ukraine russia war is inevitable right
we can talk about food security
sustainable financing for instance
russian development in such a funding
that has been banned or under sanction
of course you have impact many countries
including g20 member states
but we want this to be immediately
solved as soon as possible so it would
not buddha division and
the goals of g20 itself in november
right and just one more for you before i
bring in daniel from moscow without
russia's presence then it will be
difficult to address these economic
problems
will it not be
yes the main theme of g20 is recovered
together we cover stronger and we
definitely highlight the inclusiveness
and togetherness to this poor economic
growth at the post panamic time so
without russia it's definitely
you know it's hindered the potential of
the inclusive economic good i understand
the political crisis will give a
different story but that's definitely
something that we don't want to see in
g20 2020 by indonesia all right daniel
um you were mentioning this a moment ago
and you were talking to us about china's
position of course it hasn't condemned
the invasion of ukraine it's also
criticized western sanctions and
defended moscow as an ally uh it's
called russia an important member of the
g20 as well now the chances of one of
the g20 members like china vetoing
russia is
pretty high isn't it
well actually yes absolutely i think
that of course the majority of the g20
members they are comprised of the
countries which are currently are not
extremely
favoring what's going on between russia
and ukraine of course but still i think
that
if we again recall the example of g8 so
in order to expel russia there should be
a unanimous decision by all the members
like it happened when g7 countries
bittered russian participation and
russia back at 2013 russia was not
expelled as it is it was not just
invited to the other meetings and so
russia had no other choice but just to
withdraw its kind of
goodwill participation in such kind of
summits and so it it's not likely to
happen now because at least we have
china which has already expressed its
absolute disagreement with the idea of
return russia participation and we also
have some other states and i think that
here we can follow what's going to
happen for example from the side of
india from the site of brazil or for
example from the site of south africa
because as far as we know for example
india and south africa did not
vote in favor of the recent u.n general
assembly resolution criticized in
russian events in ukraine and so they
abstain and i think that if we speak
about upcoming g20 event uh we could
also closely monitor how greeks
countries are going to react because
as as far as we know china has already
sided with russia on g20 issue and so
what's going to happen with india south
africa and brazil it's still the matter
of time and we'll see but even with
china being against the idea of
excluding russia i think that this
initiative is not going to be
materialized in this particular sense
okay elizabeth go ahead
i mean i'd just like to say this is not
the u.n security council neither china
nor russia has a veto here it's not it
you know there's nothing laid out as
we've heard that indicates exactly how a
country can be booted from the g20 this
is a matter of invitation and if you've
got it at my account you've got at least
half of the g20 countries that i believe
are going to strongly oppose russia's
participation in the summit the
invitation is going to come from the
current g20 president which is indonesia
so it's going to be very easy for
indonesia to make that determination but
at the same time we're not talking about
a situation where there's something laid
out in the regulations here where the
g20 has to unanimously decide on
anything that they do this is it's not
an organization that works that way and
so you don't have to get china on board
if at least half of the g20 countries
oppose it and even if the decision is to
move forward and allow russia to come
then uh the boycott by a large
percentage of the countries of the g20
is going to call into question what this
organization is really good for which
brings me to my next question to you in
fact elizabeth i mean how likely is it
that other leaders will not come if the
russian president shows up
i mean i would find it very hard to
believe that you know this is months
away so we're not really sure what the
situation specifically will be but if
we're in a similar situation to what we
are and now i find it hard to believe
that the united states european
countries and other countries that have
expressed uh condemnation of this
invasion would find it easy enough to
look the other way and act as though its
business as usual with russia at this
stage uh many countries in the world are
using all of the all of the messaging
all of the tools that they have to try
and and press for a resolution to this
war and for russia to take back its
aggression aggressive stance but um
going about and acting as though
business is normal particularly when you
have massive sanctions even if this is
an economic forum
you simply can't act as though there are
other
other global crises that russia can be a
positive player in at this time so i
think it's going to be highly unlikely
to see everyone at that table
what do you think the u.s will do in
particular and is this something we see
the president president biden right now
in in brussels obviously meeting with uh
nato is this something that he's going
to be pushing for during his meetings
this week to to suspend russia or expel
russia
i mean i i don't think that's going to
be the number one priority but because
there are more urgent issues at um at
the fore right now but i do believe it's
going to be a matter of discussion and
of course with putin making the
announcement about the intention to join
the g20 summit that is put it on the
table and in the news but i imagine it's
going to be a discussion of the many
different ways that the the alliances
against russia's actions in ukraine can
make their position known and make it
harder for russia to continue to act as
though things are normal the g20 is one
of many multilateral institutions that
functions based on you know
international norms generally being
respected that's how our global economy
works so if you have one country in that
set that is flagrantly violating those
uh those norms and those rules you
cannot go to another forum that's
related to that same
global situation to that same
international
world that we all function in and just
pretend like the violations in one part
of that scenario aren't going to affect
every other one and i believe they're
going to be talking about that today and
they're going to be talking about every
form in which this issue can be raised
daniel do you agree with what elizabeth
has to say
yeah actually i would like to make one
comment to the to the elizabeth opinion
about
g20
being not an organization of course it's
not an organization but what i meant is
that it's not going to be in the way of
voting that half of the members of
organization vote against participation
of russia and so that's uh that's it
that's how it works i think that
in order to absolutely ban russia out
indonesia can only for example uh
suspend issue visas to the diplomats of
uh russia and the participants of
russian delegation but i don't see any
other possible way a way to prevent
russia from going to this event even
though uh the countries uh or all of the
half of the g20 members say that no
we're against russia but it's not going
to be a vote and it's not going to be in
this
manner and that's why actually today we
also
would see a lot of reports saying that
indonesia uh has come under
some pressure from the western countries
saying that
it should think again about whether
russia should be invited or not but
russian side has expressed its
willingness to come to the event and the
russian president
has been said that he was going to
participate at least for today we don't
know how this situation is going to
change and so just to ban russia from
the participation in this forum i think
the only possible way is just to prevent
the delegation physically coming to
indonesia and i don't see any other
possible way daniel we also hear however
let me put this to you we also hear that
um uh the reports that world trade
organization officials uh are are
reportedly refusing to meet with russian
delegations as well so to what extent do
you think is russia's
status at other uh multi-uh lateral
agencies also being questioned and does
russia care
yeah absolutely and here i actually
agree with elizabeth saying about the
boycott which could happen
if
russia comes to g20 and it could be
really a point here that if a lot of
members of g20 decide not to come
just not to share the same
uh platform with russia so of course the
impact of this organization of this
forum is going to be uh less significant
and the same happens with other
organizations yes wto has also expressed
its
uh idea to
ban russia in some future time but i
think that it's going to have a lot of
implications on world economy and world
trade because uh although russian
economy is not
that extensive as the as economists
point out still russia is the major
player on the energy market and as we
have recently noticed the market
fluctuations uh on the prices of oil and
gas uh have their own way and they would
influence uh the uh energy security of
republican union and so in this case i
think russian participation is really
important for all the countries and
let's just look at the just for the last
few minutes of the show let me bring in
thomas here and look at the broader
picture when it comes to the g20 thomas
because there are repo reports that po
the polish government is the one who
suggested to the us government that
russia should be replaced within the g20
and
it's been a long-standing goal of poland
to eventually join the the g20 is it now
seeing an opportunity to achieve that
goal and is it time for the membership
of the g20 to change
right there are some going debates that
we should add more countries to join g20
given to many countries that have
expanded their economic capacities have
advanced their economic growth and so on
and so forth but the problem now is if
we talk about ukraine and russia that
you know the concerns are not coming
from the high level government or
presidents or prime minister of western
countries but so far what i heard from
the other engagement group and working
groups that we have under the umbrella
of g20 many businesses many other
parties and stakeholders are not
demanded to
also uh excluded while shy in the
negotiation in the discussion of g20
this is a big problem again we cannot
underestimate this right and i think you
know having other member states are not
solving the problem whether we should
include russia or not but again also in
other ways exposing russia from g20 will
not also help solving the economic
problems that we have so that's why i
understand that the government of
indonesia as the president of g20 is
trying to be carefully thinking about
the best solutions to this crisis
can indonesia thomas actually use its
leadership to resolve the problems
yes indonesia has a political capital
not only by its free and active foreign
policy so what i suggest the government
to the foreign ministry is that we
should extend all of the product
capitals that we have and then trying to
solve this of course the particle
problem is number one but i agree with
everybody especially the economist that
the economic impacts are now inevitable
to this g20 member states so that's why
we should thinking hard and also trying
hard to solve this immediately elizabeth
a final word to you on the issue of the
g20 i mean not to single out poland but
there are countries other countries as
well such as
nigeria and thailand who reportedly all
have higher gdps than current g20
members so is it time that the g20
uh opened up its membership or or
reforms and starts to include other
countries what's your take on this
i certainly think that those things
should be under consideration and
discussion at this time um in addition
to the idea of you know should it be
based strictly on economic signs or
should there be other factors in such as
are you a good player in this uh you
know integrated economic international
system that we have but yes i mean
russia particularly after this set of
sanctions is no longer really at that at
that size and level so um i believe that
we should be careful about just rapidly
expanding size and reaction to the
situation uh because you have uh the i
mean it's an economic body that does
have an important kind of diplomatic
role in negotiating these issues but
they should certainly consider
the fact of which which other countries
might play a more positive um and
affirmative role in this body and if
there are countries that are creating
the types of economic issues out there
such as russia with its aggressive war
in ukraine right now then we should uh
we should consider whether or not
they're the types of countries that are
helping us resolve these problems are
causing them all right on that note
we'll leave it there thank you so much
for joining us elizabeth shackleford
daniel bochkov and thomas no sueno too
thank you so much
thanks for watching you can see the
program again anytime by visiting our
website aljazeera.com for further
discussion you can go to our facebook
page that's facebook.com forward slash
aj inside story you can join the
conversation on twitter as well our
handle is aj inside story for myself and
the whole team here in doha thanks for
watching and bye for now
[Music]